there are seven unexpected benefits from
using
baking soda now most of you probably
have baking soda in your refrigerator to
help decrease odors and you may also
know that it's good for removing stains
in your carpet and to use as a kitchen
cleaner
but there's some other really
interesting benefits that you probably
didn't hear about
now what is baking soda it is sodium
bicarbonate about four million years ago
in the area of wyoming there was a salty
lake that dried up to form what is
called trona deposits and these deposits
are basically sodium carbonate so that's
what they make sodium bicarbonate from
the sodium carbonate so most of the
baking soda sold in the world comes from
this one place in wyoming so let's talk
about number one
you can use it as a teeth whitener
because it does whiten your teeth
but it can also be used as a mouthwash
to help reduce
bacteria in your mouth especially the
ones that cause bad breath
now what's fascinating about this is
that
these microbes exist in a certain ph and
they cannot exist
in different phs
and so when you alkalize the mouth you
make an environment very difficult for
certain acid bacteria to grow as well as
the bacteria that make tartar and
plaquing and so baking soda is really
good to reduce plaquing in your teeth
and it can be used as a mild abrasive to
help clean the teeth as well so you just
take a tablespoon of baking soda and a
tablespoon of water mix it up and brush
your teeth alright that's number one all
right number two you can use it as a
natural deodorant normally sweat does
not have any odor
it's the bacteria that gives you the
odor and like i just said in number one
baking soda being alkaline changes the
ph
and can
create an environment where these
microbes cannot exist so you basically
take four tablespoons of baking soda and
four tablespoons of either
olive oil or coconut oil mix it up and
use it as a natural deodorant now i
would also add an essential oil
to give it a certain aroma you can use
lemon you can use cinnamon you can even
use lavender or even sandalwood you can
just add a couple drops and then keep it
in the refrigerator and use it as needed
all right number three you can use it to
degrade pesticides on your vegetables in
one study baking soda was found to be
the most effective
method of removing certain pesticides
from vegetables which is quite
interesting and i'll put that research
down below in the description and so of
course you want to buy organic but if
you can't always buy organic and they
spray with a pesticide or maybe a
chemical to kill worms you can basically
soak these vegetables in some baking
soda for about 12 to 15 minutes and then
rinse them off and that's going to
greatly help remove some of these
chemicals from your vegetables all right
number four
itchy skin like let's say for example
you had a bee sting or some insect bite
you can apply baking soda directly on
your skin to help greatly reduce itching
it can also help with poison ivy all
right number five
prolonged fasting okay so let's say
you're going to fast for 72
hours or longer
what happens is you're in such a state
of ketosis
that your body is going to be
excessively acid and so a little baking
soda can help reduce that acidity now
you don't have to use much i'm talking
about maybe
an eighth of a teaspoon in some water
drink it down and that can help curb
this acidity now why is acidity bad it's
not really bad but sometimes can give
you a certain odor in your breath that
you may not enjoy or people around you
might not
appreciate
all right number six
toe nail fungus
like i said in number one and two
changing the ph can greatly alter the
environment for certain microbes to
exist
there's a fascinating
research article that i put in the
description
that talks about altering the ph making
the ph more alkaline
to inhibit
viruses
and certain gram-negative
bacteria and i'm not going to mention
the virus that they're going to talk
about you can check it out before but i
will give you a little hint it's a
current virus that everyone's concerned
about right now but it's a fascinating
research article that you'll have to
check out but adding some baking soda to
toenail fungus
like an athlete's foot can reduce the
growth of that organism all right number
seven you can use it for mouth ulcers
again mouth ulcers
are usually
caused
by a virus okay so by changing the ph we
can put this virus back into remission
and get rid of these viruses
now if you haven't seen my video on the
benefits of apple cider vinegar
check it out right here
you